streit um deutschlands klimapläne die
milliarden vorhaben der bundesregierung
sorgen für diskussionen besonders
umstritten der neue co2 preis klares
signal nach spd und cdu stimmen in
brandenburg auch die grünen für
koalitionsverhandlungen und das
überraschend deutlich in münchen ist
oktoberfest und zehntausende stürmen die
theresienwiese
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers einen guten
samstagabend in allen heute um 7 ihr
überblick über diese nachrichten tag
sport nachher in der sendung mit norbert
lehmann mit der fußball-bundesliga einen
schönen guten abend auch von mir dieses
land diskutiert darüber was zu tun ist
für den klimaschutz und ob das was die
bundesregierung da gestern in ihrem
großen paket angekündigt hat zum ziel
führt es geht hoch her in der diskussion
der umstrittenste punkt der co2 preis ab
2021 soll der mit zehn euro pro tonne
starten und dann bis 2025 auf 35 euro
steigen ab 2026 kann der preis dann bis
auf 60 euro steigen wenn man das jetzt
mal ins echte leben oben rechnet würde
im ersten schritt zum beispiel der liter
benzin 2,3 cent teurer dann etwa 18 und
am ende bis zu 14 cent ist das grund um
umzusteuern frank buchwald hat die
reaktionen gesammelt
hamburg samstagmorgen viele der
autofahrer die heute hier tanken haben
verständnis für mehr klimaschutz
begeisterung klingt anders
ich muss trotzdem arbeit fahren
ich kann es nicht mehr hören ich will es
auch nicht mehr hören
er ist mir scheissegal was die
beschließen nicht weit entfernt sagt die
hamburger cdu
hier unterstützen sie das klimapaket
wenn auch nicht sehr leidenschaftlich es
ist der erste schritt man wird noch viel
mehr machen müssen aber so weit ist der
bürger auch noch nicht in der akzeptanz
dazu im prinzip ist es das richtige
und man sollte ja auch nicht so über
reagieren sondern so allmählich sich vor
arbeiten und überlegen was sinn macht
man kann nicht ad hoc jetzt loslegen und
die ganze wirtschaft alles statische
lahmlegen wenig begeisterung auch in
bochum landesparteitag der
nordrhein-westfälischen spd fielen hier
gehen die beschlüsse nicht weit genug
auch die umweltministerin hätte sich
deutlich höhere co2 preise gewünscht
droht ihren ministerkollegen gar mit
sanktionen aber
das was wir uns auf den weg bringen das
das erste mal dass es eine klare
verantwortlichkeit in der regierung
gemacht dass die ziele für die einzelnen
bereiche finden verkehr für die
industrie in einem gesetz festgelegt
werden dass festgelegt wird dass die
regierung handeln wird ökonomen sehen
das nicht so positiv zehn euro pro tonne
co2 erst mal kein großer anreiz zum
energiesparen generell reagieren die
menschen wenig auf steigende spritpreise
und steigende energiepreise
es kann nur dann reagiert werden wenn
man investiert wenn man ihn neue
haushalt zum investiert das gebäude
modernisiert das auto austauscht und
dann muss man halt darauf achten dass es
dann spaß immer wird viel arbeit wartet
deshalb auf handwerker heizungsbauer
energieberater leute wie erik scherer
aus dem saarland auch er aber sagt das
dauert ich denke man muss die
bevölkerung mitnehmen und dazu braucht
eine gewisse zeit diesen wandel
herbeizuführen
viele details sind noch offen das
klimapaket ein anfang und für die
politik ein ballon sagt und mir zu
diesem großen thema gibt es auch online
bei uns auf heute.de
hier finden sie unter anderem interviews
und reaktionen auf das klimaschutzpaket
und einen überblick über all die
beschlüsse wirklich schwung in eine
weltweite klimaschutz debatte hat sie
gebracht greta nürnberg damals 15 jahre
alt setzte sich im letzten sommer vor
den schwedischen reichstag und rief auf
zum schulstreik für das klima ein jahr
später hat sie ihr schild immer noch
dabei doch mittlerweile ist sie nicht
mehr alleine sondern anführerin einer
protestbewegung auf dem ganzen globus
gestern sprach sie new york vor
zehntausenden demonstranten heute ist
sie dabei beim klima beim jugend
klimagipfel der vereinten nationen in
new york von dort johannes hano
mit einer indianischen segnung zeremonie
wurde der gipfel heute morgen in new
york eröffnet eine prophezeiung des
häuptlings crazy horse habe sich erfüllt
harte zeiten stünden der menschheit
bevor nur gemeinsam könne man die großen
probleme lösen
der zeitpunkt sei jetzt gekommen
millionen hatten gestern weltweit für
eine neue klimapolitik demonstriert
allein in new york waren es 250.000 die
der ikone der bewegung zujubelten heute
hielt sich greta thunberg aber zurück
ich möchte nicht so viel zeit in
anspruch nehmen ich sollte schon am
montag auf dem weltklimagipfel sprechen
ich möchte den anderen aber mehr zeit
geben hier zu sprechen
600 jugendliche aus der ganzen welt
nehmen an dem gipfel teil 100 von ihnen
hatte die uno eine co2 neutrale anreise
finanziert und die jugendlichen machten
dem anwesenden un-generalsekretär
unmissverständlich klar worum es ihnen
geht
wir müssen fordern dass die 100 firmen
die für 71 prozent des weltweiten
treibhausgasausstoßes verantwortlich
sind sich auf einen weg zu mehr
nachhaltigkeit gegeben wir können das
schaffen wenn wir zusammenhalten und
sagen
genug ist genug wir wollen keine
fossilen brennstoffe mehr
der un generalsekretär diesen ersten
welt jugend klimagipfel ins leben
gerufen hatte forderte die jugendlichen
auf weiterzumachen
meine generation hat eine große
verantwortung aber es ist eure
generation die uns in die verantwortung
nehmen muss damit wir die zukunft der
menschheit nicht verraten
bei dem gipfel aber geht es nicht nur um
kritik vor einer jury aus
internationalen wirtschaftslenkern
präsentieren die jungen delegierten ihre
ganz konkreten projekte für eine bessere
zukunft
nach den drohnenangriffen auf zwei
saudiarabische ölanlagen vergangene
woche verlegen die usa zusätzliche
streitkräfte in die golfregion
das kündigte das
verteidigungsministerium an es handelt
sich um eine moderate verstärkung der
truppen und die entscheidung sei eine
reine verteidigungsmaßnahmen vor allem
die raketenabwehr soll gestärkt werden
die usa machen den iran für die attacke
verantwortlich teheran weist die
vorwürfe zurück
zurück nach deutschland und zu einem
ungewohnten farbenspiel in brandenburg
drei wochen nach der landtagswahl rot
schwarz grün eine regierung aus spd cdu
und grünen die sogenannte genial
koalition wünscht sich
spd-ministerpräsident dietmar woidke und
wünschen sich jetzt auch die grünen
heute gab es dafür eine mehrheit auf dem
kleinen parteitag
schon montag sollen die
koalitionsverhandlungen beginnen
rot-grün-rot wäre rein theoretisch auch
denkbar gewesen hätte aber nur eine
stimme mehrheit zu wenig für eine
stabile regierung findet der
ministerpräsident kommt jetzt also kenia
bettina warten berichtet große
erleichterung und jubel bei den
verhandlungsführern der grünen mehr als
85 prozent der delegierten auf dem
kleinen parteitag stimmten für die
aufnahme von koalitionsverhandlungen mit
spd und cdu
das ergebnis fiel deutlicher aus als
erwartet das war klar dass das für uns
eine schwierige hürde wert der
widerstände aus der partei gerade aus
der grünen jugend waren doch erheblich
die nachwuchsorganisation wollte lieber
eine koalition mit spd und linken
sie versuchten das ungeliebte kenia
bündnis zu verhindern wir sind nicht
dafür da der spd ihre wunschkoalition
für wirklich zu verwirklichen und
deswegen sage ich china zu killen ja
doch ein wichtiges ziel konnten die
grünen schon erreichen kein dorf in
brandenburg soll mehr dem tagebau
geopfert werden proschim mit 320
einwohnern sollte dem braunkohleabbau
weichen jetzt ist es gerettet so steht
es im sondierungs papier und deswegen
haben wir das in dieses papier
eingeschrieben weil es keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist sondern weil
es essentiell ist um proschim und die
anderen gebiete vor ort in der lausitz
zu erhalten
am ende waren noch spd und cdu damit
einverstanden sie stimmten vorher mit
einem klaren ja zu kenia wir haben
differenzen überbrückt in dem gemeinsam
ziel dass wir für dieses land eine
stabile tragfähige regierung bilden
wollen ich kann jeden satz dieses
papiers dieses sondierungs papiers
unterschreiben ich hätte aber nicht
jeden satz selber so geschrieben
ab montag verhandeln die parteien das
mögliche neue bündnis in drei monaten
muss die regierung in brandenburg stehen
und in fünf wochen dann die nächste
landtagswahl im osten in thüringen auch
da dürfte die regierungsbildung nicht
einfach werden spannend vor allem die
frage ob es für die jetzige rot rot
grüne koalition wieder reicht
regierungschef ist seit 2014 bodo
ramelow
übrigens der erste ministerpräsident der
linken in deutschland
andreas postel hat sich den wahlkampf
angeguckt sie schlagen nicht reden okay
soweit sind die regeln klar auf dem
erfurter kinderfest wie auch im
wahlkampf
der weltkindertag gestern zum ersten mal
gesetzlicher feiertag in thüringen
eingeführt durch die rot rot grüne
koalition von deutschlands einzigem
linken ministerpräsidenten wir haben
zusammen fünf jahre dieses land gut
entwickelt wir haben in diesem land
gezeigt dass man als dreier koalition
handlungsfähig ist wir haben auch
gezeigt dass man mit einer einzigen
stimme mehrheit aus bestehend aus drei
parteien eine koalition bilden kann und
gemeinsam gut arbeiten kann
das sieht der cdu herausforderer ganz
anders mike mohring will kämpfen um
seine partei zurück in die
regierungsverantwortung zu führen wir
wollen das land an die spitze der
deutschen länder bringen und das geht
eben nur mit einer starken stimme in
berlin
und es geht vor allem mit einer idee für
dieses land stadt und land zu versöhnen
besserer bildung anzubieten hier fallen
eine million unterrichtsstunden pro
schuljahr aus dass einfach unerträglich
bildung laut umfragen wichtigstes
wahlkampfthema am freistaat bei der afg
gibt es zum wahlkampfauftakt den größten
applaus beim thema abschiebung und
spitzenmann blöcke träumt von der
regierungsübernahme
staaten lassen und es wird mir
persönlich eine freude sein
beim ersten flug vom ersten abflug auf
dem flughafen zu stehen und zu winkel
gute heimreise mit dem ehemaligen
gymnasiallehrer aus hessen will niemand
koalieren des völkischen nationaler
flügel wird vom verfassungsschutz als
verdachtsfall eingestuft das erbe der
friedlichen revolution neben 30 jahre
danach bündnis 90 die grünen für sich in
anspruch in der stark polarisierten
gesellschaft hoffen sie mit globalen
klimaschutz auch im ländlich geprägten
thüringen zu punkten nachhaltige
landwirtschaft dass es zukunft
mobilitätsgarantie für den ländlichen
raum und daseinsvorsorge das ist zukunft
und ganz entschlossenes handeln raus aus
der klimakrise das gibt es mit uns mit
uns als grün und hoffentlich in dieser
koalition rot-rot-grün über fortsetzen
wollen allerdings droht
koalitionspartner spd zwischen links und
rechts aufgerieben zu werden und das
trotz guter wirtschaftlicher entwicklung
in thüringen wir wollen in der nächsten
regierung rot rot grün die
stabilisierende die ausgleichende kraft
sein mit starken ministerien jetzt haben
wir finanzen wirtschaft wissenschaft
innere sicherheit kommunales wir prägen
dieses land und das wollen wir auch
weitermachen und deshalb werben wir um
vertrauen
sollte die fdp wieder in den landtag
einziehen wird die regierungsbildung
nicht leichter auch auf eine
minderheitsregierung ist bodo ramelow
eingestellt es wird ein enger wahlkampf
bis zum 27
oktober wir bleiben nur einen moment in
den ostdeutschen bundesländern da ist
die wirtschaftsleistung in den letzten
jahren deutlich gestiegen
das berichten verschiedene medien und
berufen sich auf den jahresbericht
deutsche einheit der bundesregierung im
vergleich zum westen lag die
wirtschaftskraft im osten im vergangenen
jahr bei 75 prozent
1990 waren es nur 43 prozent
löhne gehälter und private einkommen
erreichen inzwischen etwa 85 prozent des
westdeutschen niveaus und jetzt eher
ernüchternde zahlen es geht um frauen in
führungspositionen und da hängt
deutschland weiter hinterher nur knapp
15 prozent der vorstände in den dax
unternehmen sind frauen und damit kaum
mehr als vor einem jahr
in den usa sind es immerhin doppelt so
viele 30 prozent
in schweden und großbritannien
gut 20 prozent zahlen die die albright
stiftung errechnet hat frauenministerin
franziska giffey will da mehr tempo rein
bringen und das gesetzlich regeln
das gedächtnis lässt nach die
erinnerungen verblassen so fängt für
viele eine krankheit an die menschen
nach und nach alles vergessen lässt
alsheimer 1,7 millionen menschen in
deutschland leiden an demenz
erkrankungen und weil wir immer älter
werden und die zahl der betroffenen
steigt bis heute gibt es kein medikament
das die krankheit heilen kann
moderne technik wie virtual reality
brillen sollen jetzt helfen die
erinnerungen länger wach zu halten
darüber berichtet gabi handelt heute am
weltalzheimertag wenn die
vergesslichkeit zunimmt sind zeitreisen
in die vergangenheit eine möglichkeit
erinnerungen aufzufrischen
zum beispiel mit 3d brillen alexandra
kasper ist sozialer betreuerin im kölner
altenheim sankt matthäus margarete
miebach mag die reise in die virtuelle
welt
sie ging schon immer gerne in museen
doch nun schaut sie bilder von van gogh
durch die 3d brille
sie wird vergesslich wie das so ist bei
menschen mit einer demenz für mich wenn
man sowas gut kennt dann findet man das
toll
es geht darum erinnerungen wach zu
halten
auch marianne hertwig liebt diese
ausflüge in die vergangenheit ihr
lieblingsziel der kölner dom es schafft
die möglichkeit sich an orte zu begeben
ohne zu verreisen also reisen ohne zu
verreisen und das bereichert den alltag
ungemein
natürlich sind 3d brillen kein
allheilmittel gegen demenz und nicht
jeder versteht was er da sieht aber man
spürt das gesehene beschäftigt und wer
fragen stellt ist im austausch und zeigt
bereits jetzt ein ganz anderes thema wir
schauen nach münchen auf die
theresienwiese da ist wieder oktoberfest
das 186 bestes wetter riesenandrang und
auch der oberbürgermeister hat seinen
job schnell erledigt jetzt fließt das
bier in strömen claudia vogel man ist
dort im springt zum bierzelt so beginnt
das oktoberfest wenige minuten nach
einlass waren die 120.000 plätze in den
wiesn zelten belegt demonstrierten
einige besucher gäste noch bei freies
for future haben sich heute viele fans
bedenkenlose feiern entschieden
die sich endlich wieder ein bisschen auf
die straße traut und traut was zu sagen
und ich glaube da kann man sich am
nächsten tag auch in devisen setzte in
welchen trinken auf den ersten schluck
muss julia noch drei stunden warten denn
erst nach dem einzug der festwirte und
schausteller wird punkt 12 angezapft für
die besucher kostet die maß bier bis zu
11 euro 80 das größte volksfest der welt
wird mit ökostrom versorgt wer viel co2
erzeugt kann das mit dem kauf von öko
zertifikaten ausgleichen
die wiesn wird mit dem thema
nachhaltigkeit
[Musik]
und wer thema nachhaltigkeit besonders
hervortut wir kommen besonders viele
punkte
damit erhöhen sich die chancen auf einen
heiß begehrten standplatz auf dem
oktoberfest beim essen greifen die
besucher immer noch gerne bei händel und
enten zu doch in der käfer wiesn schänke
wird immer häufiger fleischloses essen
bestellt wir machen vor allem dieses
super thema salate so indianernesseln so
spezielle salate mit nüssen blüten bild
salat es wird definitv trend dieses jahr
werden dazu ein veganes bier nach dem
bayerischen reinheitsgebot ein fest dass
drinnen wie draußen schöne stunden
verspricht und sie rennen sie rennen sie
rennen aber eins ist glas bier wird
reichen
hoffentlich ein bisschen wie man
sommerschlussverkauf früher war so aus
du bleibst beim thema sport passend zum
oktoberfest zumindest aus münchner sicht
die fußball bundesliga der feiern die
bayern auch nämlich ihren heimsieg über
köln und ihr stürmer robert lewandowski
der feiert seine saisontore 8 und 9 nach
nur fünf spieltagen das gab es das
letzte mal vor über 50 jahren hier die
bisherigen ergebnisse bayern schlägt
köln 4 zu 0 leverkusen gewinnt gegen
union berlin mit 2 0 hat das erster
saisonsieg 2 zu 1 gegen aufsteiger
paderborn freiburg und augsburg trennen
sich unentschieden 1 1 im abendspiel
trifft bremen auf leipzig schon gestern
abend gewann schalke gegen mainz 4 2 2 1
die sonntagsspiele gladbach gegen
düsseldorf von frankfurt gegen dortmund
am montag dann doch wolfsburg gegen
hoffenheim ja die tabelle
die bayern sind mit 11 punkten erster
aber leipzig heute abend und dortmund
morgen die können die münchner wieder
verdrängen freiburg jetzt zweiter danach
leipzig schalke und leverkusen allesamt
mit zehn punkten dann dortmund mit neun
punkten sechster die zweite
tabellenhälfte
die beginnt mit bremen hertha hat die
rote laterne nach dem heimsieg abgegeben
und ist jetzt fünfzehnter dahinter köln
mainz und aufsteiger paderborn neuer
tabellenletzter
ja und das am spiel bremen gegen leipzig
bei uns zu sehen im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr zu gast bei jochen
breyer josua kimmig vom fc bayern
münchen nach der ernüchternden
gruppenphase bei der volleyball-em dreht
vize meister europameister deutschland
jetzt richtig auf und besiegte im
achtelfinale gastgeber niederlande mit 3
2 sätzen
das dvv team mit traumstart nach dem
souveränen gewinn des ersten satzes
entscheidet deutschland auch den zweiten
für sich umkämpft dagegen der dritte
durchgang die niederlande zwei mal drei
punkte in führung doch das team von
bundestrainer giovanni kämpft sich
wieder heran und hat matchbälle doch
alle sechs möglichkeiten zum sieg
bleiben ungenutzt
auch der vierte satz spannend und erneut
matchbälle für das dvv team bei
matchball nummer acht erzwingt
mittelblocker anton krämer den sieg in 3
1 sätzen im viertelfinale am montag
trifft das wieder erstarkte deutsche
team auch weltmeister polen oder
gruppengegner spanien
starker auftritt auch von ferrari beim
qualifying zum großen preis von singapur
schale claire startet von der pole
position vor weltmeister lewis hamilton
und teamkollege sebastian vettel
ein sichtlich ernüchtert hat sebastian
vettel nach dem qualifying in dem er
sich im letzten abschnitt mit einer
beherzten fahrt zunächst deutlich an die
spitze setzt am ende aber wird vettel
wieder von seinem teamkollegen scharen
le claire überholt und dann auch noch
von lewis hamilton
das herz heute in der hand das speed war
da und deswegen bin ich natürlich nicht
nicht ganz zufrieden trotzdem glaube ich
sind wir für morgen in einer guten
position vor allem aber jahren glücklich
mit der dritten pole position
nacheinander von platz drei ist für
sebastian vettel aber im rennen noch
alles möglich das war es von mir genauso
schöne aussichten vom wetter es wird
fast überall sonnig und warm erst morgen
abend ändert sich das dann ein bisschen
im westen
alle details gleich von gunther tiersch
das heute schon mal 22 uhr 45 da freut
sich marietta slomka auf sie und vom
gesamten heute 19 uhr team danke fürs
interesse in allen einen angenehmen
samstagabend
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer es wird
morgen nochmals sonnig und warm in
mitteleuropa warmluft von frankreich
benelux zieht morgen wie eine warme luft
blasen so ein bisschen über mitteleuropa
hinweg danach wird es ein bisschen
frischer nächste woche auch am
mittelmeer ist nicht mehr ganz so heißt
20 bis 30 grad aber das ist ja noch sehr
angenehm aber wie gesagt ab montag kommt
die luft aus westen und das bedeutet
eben kühleres wetter
das wird sich die ganze nächste woche
bei uns festsetzt mit 15 bis 20 grad und
es geht ja auch noch die nächte sind
nicht mehr ganz so kalt heute nacht noch
mal drei grad im östlichen bayern
vielleicht noch leichten frost sonst ist
es milder sternenklaren morgen scheint
dann erst einmal die sonne im norden ist
es auch wolkenlos im südwesten ziehen im
tagesverlauf ein paar wolken heran
dazu haben diesen kräftigen südostwind
erst gegen abend bilden sich
wahrscheinlich westlich des rheins die
ersten regenschauer angenehm die
temperatur am morgen meist zwischen 23
und 27 grad etwas frischer noch an der
küste oder auch im östlichen bayern und
dann kommt der regen am montag und auch
weiterhin dienstag/mittwoch es ist
wechselhaft und nicht mehr ganz so warm
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut